harry kazianis is the president of the
rogue states project he joins us tonight
to assess where china is and all this
harry thanks so much for coming on so i
guess the question is to what extent is
china bluffing if any what do you think
oh tucker i'm going to be honest with
you they're not bluffing at all they
have been preparing for this scenario
for 30 years if you go back to 1995 1996
we had a similar situation with with
china when taiwan's president would want
to come back to cornell university to
visit his alma mater we had a very
similar crisis but at the time the
united states was the overwhelming
military superpower we had no problems
worrying about china in fact chinese
military officials couldn't even find
our aircraft carriers today the
situation is very different the chinese
have prepped for this scenario they have
thousands of ballistic cruise missiles
hypersonic missiles carrier killer
missiles so if there was ever a war
between the united states and china the
first thing they are going to do is they
are going to attack with a bolt from the
blue they're going to destroy our
satellites in orbit they're going to
destroy our communications equipment
we're not going to be fighting about
transgender issues on tick-tock anymore
because tick-tock's not going to work in
the united states and then they're going
to destroy our aircraft carriers destroy
all of our bases in asia this has all
been war gamed out i've actually fought
this war in simulators for over 10 years
you know what happens every time tucker
we lose
so i i mean everyone prays it would
never get to a point anywhere near what
you described but of course it could and
the chinese have not been
i don't think very subtle about
telegraphing their intentions in the
face of this looming threat from this
rising power
how has the entire united states
congress sat back and continued to fund
a military that gets weaker and more
politicized every year i don't
understand that
i i don't either talk to be honest with
you i mean a lot of this is
misprioritization i mean i it feels like
we're forever stuck in a cold war
mindset i mean we're forever stuck in
this idea that we're the dominant
hegemon a lot of our foreign policy
thinking seems like it's stuck in the
1990s you know the unipolar moment if
you will where the united states is
omnipotent can do anything nothing can
happen to us you know we've got the
atlantic the pacific we've got canada
and mexico and nothing can permeate our
our you know our space but i think 911
proved that that you know obviously can
happen and i think china proves that
this throat is very real and let's face
it tucker we're not ready for it yeah
and if this moment doesn't freeze the
renewable energy cult in its tracks and
makes a laughing stock of anybody
suggest turning our grid over to china i
you know i don't know honestly what will
harry great to see john thank you for
that
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight